hello and congratulations good to see
you hi you hi hi Jim I'll apologize in
advance I have a big old compound
question for you to start here because I
was reading oh I was reading a quote in
our production notes about how a goal of
Gracie Films has always been to support
the voices of articulate filmmakers so I
was wondering what's one way that you go
about doing that that has stayed the
same since day one when you first
started the company but then on the
other hand what's something about what
it takes to make that happen for a
filmmaker that has had to change given
how the industry's evolved over the
years writer's rule that's that's that
that that's been true that was our idea
when we started it and that's and that's
you know and writer always has control
over uh his material his or her material
whether whether it's by directing or
being a really active producer and we
that's never enough in the case I love
the sound of that how about uh something
about that that's evolved for you given
how uh the industry has changed since
the beginning of the company you know is
there there are tougher times and easier
times but but it but but really that
that that that ethos or whatever it is
has never changed and I know and it
won't it won't it's um and and a lot of
a lot of Writers Do directing for the
first time as part of that I like that
Compass right there I hope you stick
with it forever and ever
um
I'll stick with uh Gracie Films for a
moment because I was thinking a little
bit about the film and also the book and
how they're all about how you know key
early influences can make a big deal in
someone's life growing up so if I turn
that idea towards your career what's
something about the people at Gracie
Films and the company's goals that now
make you think like I am so glad that I
started there with those people I I'm
incredibly lucky I mean you know what
we're always about the work you know and
about making these movies and I've
honestly never worked on a movie that I
haven't been proud of and loved and I
don't know that many people can say that
in the industry she did leave briefly
well briefly but then I screw it I screw
it back because I saw a reality and
didn't like it
um but yeah it's it's a privilege to be
able to do that and to and to help
writer directors you know and get their
Vision on screen I mean it's really it's
an amazing thing to be able to do the
great the great you know we never talk
about it but the great thing is that
everybody who works there there aren't
that many no they're small yeah yeah
works on everything yep I wish more more
companies out there would Embrace that
mentality I wanted to ask you both about
casting this movie because there was
another quote in our notes that said the
best movies are a combination of a great
script and also the Perfect cast to go
with that script and I very much believe
in that and I feel like you hit that
right here so I was wondering which role
in the film would you say it was the
easiest to cast where the right actor
just magically presented themselves but
then also which role proved most
difficult to find the perfect fit for
that's easy uh Rachel is easiest
and uh Margaret was the hardest I mean
Abby Abby was there was no SEC we saw
thousands of girls and there was nobody
in second place
yeah when she walked in the door
thank God that then we knew we had a
movie I can very much understand that
she is something else in the way she
carries this film
um I always love asking about overcoming
challenges on set so can you both give
me an example of a time during the
making of this movie when something on
set wasn't working quite right you had
to find a creative way to Pivot and you
wound up finding some unexpected magic
that made a particular part of the film
even better off for it
did it go that easily
well you know if your coffee was late
one morning and it was pretty tough
we did do something on this movie that
was a little different I
a two-week break in the middle and I
think was a great thing to do and maybe
more production if you could do it can
because it really allowed us time to
kind of think about what we've done we
worked with the kids in the first part
of the movie and then the adults in the
second and it really I think
aided it in some sort of it just gave us
that time to think in when you don't
always have time to think when you're in
the kind of Hell of production oh
absolutely I love that you were able to
incorporate that here
um personal question for both of you to
end here because this this book and now
this movie is going to wind up being you
know a pretty pivotal part of people's
lives and how they experience and
process growing up so I was wondering
what is what is the movie version of
that for you the movie that you turn to
that you know made you feel seen
answered your questions and offered you
guidance when you were growing up
I'd say Network solid choice right there
yeah I mean I there's different things
you look to movies for I mean I weirdly
the movie being there
spoke to me in some way I mean it's just
I I it made me want to get into into
being in working in films both excellent
choices excellent movie congratulations
thank you the fact that I walked out of
this film and said to myself I can't
wait to share this with my niece means
the world to me so thank you great
thanks a lot